this is part of history and history is
taking place today the world is upon us
the World wishes to watch this big big
occasion and to be a just a small Cog in
this major occasion is something special
to me so Lindsay Hoyle has enjoyed the
privilege of witnessing history being
made on many many occasions
but today dressed in his robe of state
and antique Hornet and Lace
staring back at him from the mirror is
not the Speaker of the House of Commons
but an all-struck little lad from
Chorley in Lancashire nobody's ever seen
it or the majority of us never seen
anything like this before the tragedy of
Her Majesty's passing was an amazing go
London came together the world wanted to
watch it that was the downside this is
the upside this is the coronation the
new king a new beginning
protocol and procedure Pomp and
pageantry they've defined the king's
coronation and playing his small but
important role in today's proceedings
was Lord Narendra Patel who presented
the king with his ring received this
ring what was going through my mind
despite the many rehearsals I done if I
drop it this is the tower for me so I
was relieved not to have dropped it but
I was there at his coronation
which was fantastic
sound the whole theater of its colors
and the music was extraordinary
among the greats and the good lucky
enough to have been invited to the
ceremony was danger and alumni this
country can do spectacle and when it
comes to royalty in in great Cathedrals
and Abbeys they do it the best but I
think there's something about the
Perfection the everything was precise
the music was ravishing not everyone
here inside the Abbey was invited for
being famous Rianne Manning's charity
work earned her a special invitation
you see it from a distance all the time
but to know that you're part of
something and witnessing something that
really got me emotional obviously when
they walked out and were wearing the
king and queen were wearing their their
crowns I I did shed a little tear I have
to be honest
follow the king's coronation from around
the world but only the most fortunate
we're here to experience history being
made for themselves
a momentous day that will live with them
forever oh she's joshing Sky News in
central London
[Music]